you can't be afraid to fail that voice
in my head that was like man this is
scary and the other voice was like
that's why we're doing it if you don't
put yourself in uncomfortable positions
it's hard to get any growth there cuz
you will fail like if you try to do epic
[__] you're going to fail the coward and
the hero feel the same exact emotion
when confronted with a situation it's
just how do you act in response to the
fear if there is one word to describe
Ken WR out I would say that word is
authentic he is the real deal he's
always unapologetically himself and he's
back today for a glorious round two back
in August of 2022 Ken on his first
appearance on the podcast shared Tales
from his rough Boston upbringing his
journey from prison guard to Wall Street
the opioid addiction that nearly broke
him and his metamorphosis into one of
the world's preeminent Master athletes a
guy who has posted a 228 Marathon at age
50 and a guy who consistently racks Up
titles at some of the planet's most
prestigious races including a recent age
group world championship title at last
month's Chicago Marathon today we go
deeper into what motivates his
beast-like drive we talk about the whats
and the how's behind his professional
approach to training and racing along
with an array of powerful lessons on the
mindset discipline consistency and
humility
that keeps him getting better and faster
into his 50s and we do all of this
through Ken recapping his very first
Ultra experience the GOI March which is
this brutal 155 M Race Across the
Mongolian desert that Ken not only
finished but actually won it and he won
it by over 84 minutes Ken is
extraordinary his stories are just wild
and his council is both inspiring and
and actionable so here we go round two
with Ken ride
[Music]
out good to see you man good to see you
brother we talked way too much before
this thing started that's all right we I
have a short memory yeah but let's start
off with uh what's been happening
recently because you just uh notched
your belt with a few interesting
experiences right to the least seven
days out in the desert in Mongolia doing
this goby March your first Ultra I
remember when uh you pinged me and
you're like hey I'm going to do this
thing I'm thinking about signing up for
this race and I was like call me we got
to talk you you I was telling you guys
you lit a fire under my ass I had
initially told a friend of mine called
James Davies who's like a CEO at
Deutsche Bank I knew he was familiar
with like marathon doab and a few Ultra
events that he knew we had talked about
them before in passing and I said yo you
know this race and he's like yeah that
would be great I said I'm thinking of
doing it am I crazy and he said uh oh if
you could get top five in that man that
would be wildly impressive and
immediately I was like top five what the
[__] is this guy I'm winning and I was
like I know it sounds irrational but
there's like almost like two voices in
my head there's one that's like trying
to like create like self-preservation
and another one that's like just a
little bit louder that's like we can win
anything we want so one guy's like dude
don't do that you're going to embarrass
us please we don't know what we're doing
I know from Iron Man when you do those
longer events there's just so many
things you don't know for the first time
like when experience counts for so much
I know that I've never run with a
backpack I've never slept in a tent I
take two showers a day no shower for
seven days I was like am I crazy I but
the other voice was like [__] that let's
do this we'll figure it out on the Fly
it'll be a real Challenge and like let's
get uncomfortable yeah and then I and
then and then when I text you and you
like oh that's a claimed many Ultra
Runners all I heard was you're not tough
enough for that and oh that's what you
heard yes that's not what I was saying I
know what I was what I said as I recall
was you got to toss out the window
everything you think you know about
running a race because all the um
experience that you've had running
marathons obviously there's value in
that but this is a whole different
animal and you know you got to like let
go of pushing the pace and it's all
about economy and efficiency and the
discipline is is ented around holding
back and choosing your moments and you
know sort of conserving your energy
which is I I wouldn't think that that is
your strong suit I did none of that you
did and then I told you to call how
right did you did you speak to him I
spoke to how I spoke to Charlie Angel
who won it the first year they held it
and um but again when you said it
claimed many Ultra Runner I was like it
hasn't claimed me yet and I was like I
knew what you meant I knew you had the
best intentions but I use that as like
motivation I was like I signed up as
soon as I got that text from you I was
like I'm in I'm doing it and then I
talked to Charlie and it's funny in
hindsight he was like no you don't
really need poles you don't really need
Gators for your shoes I needed
everything I mean at one point we were
going up a mountain on the first stage
and the two kids who were competitive
with me an Israeli and a Swiss athlete
they blew past me with poles and left me
like for dead and I was hands on knees
trying to get up like a you know like a
black diamond ski slope and it wasn't on
a trail it was just up the side of a
mountain it was so crazy every day I
felt like asking someone like how did
you guys get liability insurance this is
the most dangerous thing I've ever done
by far I remember thinking that when I
did otillo and we're out in open water
and the sea is pitching you know 7 foot
swells and the boats are going like this
I was like this race would never happen
in the United States there's no way
right what did uh it's interesting why
did Charlie tell you not to have polls
you would think that he would have had
experience to say yeah I guess in
hindsight I could make a case for not
having them but I think I would have
been better off with them but still it
wasn't like obviously it wasn't
detrimental but after the first day so
back to your point about being
patient first day we so you want me to
like walk through as quickly like this
let let's just explain what the race is
um the GOI March seven days seven stages
155 miles how did it break down so it
was like um there was a there was a rest
day in there cuz on the 50 m day people
take more than 24 hours so it was um 21
mil 28
2450 on the Wednesday but then you don't
go again till Friday which that was one
of the hardest parts for me like
finishing Wednesday at 5:00 p.m. and not
racing again till Friday morning like
hanging out in the camp with
freeze-dried food like starving I was
burning 10,000 calories a day and eating
2500 every single day but in a weird way
my and Char had mentioned this he's like
you'll get stronger as the week goes by
just like have you ever noticed it like
if you go to a cycling training camp by
the end you're a beast and like second
or third day you're like I'm never going
to be able to finish this but your body
is so freaking resilient that it just it
adapted adjusted to the food it adjusted
to everything and like everything was
like functioning regularly except my
sleep was just [__] terrible sleeping
on the grounds on a on a thin mat with a
sleeping bag oh I got two hours of sleep
the night after the 50 mile stage and
three hours the following night I just
could not sleep but during the 50 mile
stage I had taken a ton of caffeinated
um hydration tablets that I picked up
from someone who dropped out so I was
just way too I don't I don't metabolize
caffeine well but you're you're charged
up enough it is to say the least so then
after that 50 you have that day off and
then you have I think it's a marathon
and then it ends with a five mile yeah
so so I I'll quickly walk through like
the progression so you get into I get
into Mongolia let's say on Friday
Saturday they drive us out into the
desert and we camp that night and um I
had brought they said you could bring a
one-man tent if you wanted so I was like
yeah I don't want to sleep in a communal
tent I'll bring a I'll bring a Onan tent
again not knowing anything I get the
smallest tent you can get like a bicycle
tent that you can take on a bike trip
and I get there and the people in the
oneman tents are in tents that look like
they could camp on Everest and I'm like
d this this tent practically has two
rooms in it like I've got a tent that
like I can barely fit in so before the
thing started I asked the organizers I
basically was like oh one of my tent PS
got bent in transit is there any chance
I could jump into one of these communal
tents and she was like yeah there's a
tent you can get in that one and the
first night dude it pours it's raining
sideways I'm like oh my God the tent's
going to blow away I don't I'm having an
anxiety attack I don't know anyone I'm
like I feel like an outsider it's very
clicky everyone knows each other they
weren't unfriendly but no one was like
overly friendly to me whatsoever and
before I had gotten there the organizer
was like oh my God I had sent her some
articles about my background and stuff
so she let me in with like four weeks to
go and uh she's like I'll put this all
in your bio I said I'd rather not just I
don't want anything in my bio I don't
want anyone to know I'm coming I kind of
want it to creep up on like playing mind
games yeah from the beginning so uh yeah
so we wake up and we go the first day
and sure enough two three guys take it
out super hard and I'm like holy [__]
this is going to be the pace I figured
I'm I'm going to win a die trying so I'm
just going to stay with the leaders I'm
not going to lead but I'm going to stay
with them and uh funny cuz there was a
British kid who was just fraking flying
and uh he ended up not finishing and
we're running I'm like yo are you a
marathon runner he's like I haven't run
a marathon but I run half marathons I'm
like oh what's your PR he's like 107 I'm
like oh for Christ sake this guy can run
so um yeah but but to my earlier point
this you know how relevant is that in a
7-Day race clearly not at all cuz
he was out after like days that's wild
what was the training like leading up to
it did you just sck to your 10 mil a day
routine and just went into it for four
weeks I um i r i cycled through maybe um
four or five different backpacks until I
found one that wouldn't like burn holes
in my back when I the chafing on my back
and my hips in my waist was it was
unbearable unbearable like bleeding
every day and um well it's good that you
tested that out ahead of time showed up
with a backpack and and just to be clear
self-supported means you're carrying all
your food in your backpack are you
carrying your tents also like everything
that you need no they the only thing
that they would transport for you the
tent thing the the tent thing which I
didn't end up using was new because of
coid they gave people the option if you
didn't want to be in a communal tent in
the last two years and they've just kept
it so there was only like five or 10
people that had a single man tent but
you could also because of because of
coid they they wanted all the doors to
stay open so they would allow allow you
to send a supplemental backpack so of
course I hear this and like all I'm
thinking is like strategy right and how
can I win so she tells me it's like go
so let me get this straight if I carry
like you had to have a backpack a
sleeping bag that went down to 32
degrees so 0 Celsius so that had to be
rated down there so I got a high-tech
like Ceda Summit sleeping bag but I said
for the supplemental like hypothetically
if I had one that went down to 50 below
that was super thick like a massive
camping sleep mag she's like yeah
everyone so that's what I got so I would
lay that down and sleep on top of that
with my other sleeping bag so that kind
of provided some Pat and I had an
inflatable like little cushion thing
that I but my backpack at the beginning
without water weighed 21 PBS and the
other the Swiss guy who was like the
main competition his backpack at the
start weighed like 14 lbs right and it
was streamlined and he had won like
three of these races and dude it was
funny we were sitting there the day
before I was sitting with my friend
Scott Dar who's the president of Equinox
who's originally told me about the race
that he was doing the race and um I had
never met him in person just via email
and uh was sitting there and a
photographer from the race sits down
with us in Mongolia at this hotel we're
at and he's like oh I said hey are there
any guys here who have won before he's
like oh reinold so and so's here from
Switzerland he's won like three of them
he's unbelievable I was like oh okay and
the guy doesn't know me I don't know him
so I'm like all right Ryan holds the guy
he's going down so in my mind I'm like
I'm killing this guy uhhuh so uh he's
got everything dialed I mean he's he's
Flawless his he all his [__] is perfect
like Special Forces he's like Special
Forces and I'm like the guy from stripes
the movie Stripes just like completely
disheveled in h but you got the unknown
factor yes yeah um you know it's it's
interesting in thinking about preparing
for this you tested out the backpacks
but ideally I would imagine you know it
probably would have been good to do some
rucking on loose sand or go to to sand
dunes and you know all that kind of
stuff you didn't do any of that I tested
out a bunch of shoes I went through
maybe four or five pair of shoes because
the nice thing is with the consistency
of the training that I've done when I
add on like if I try a new pair of shoes
and run 10 or 15 miles you know by the
end if something's even slightly a miss
so I tried a few got a few blisters here
and there knew what to do and then uh
Hoka came through and actually sent me
some great like speed goats and um
another model that I can't think of like
a Top Trail shoe but not the speed goat
and that's the one that I went with so
they sent me two of those but you know
with trail shoes the bottom is so hard
if you're running on um concrete it's
almost counterproductive it like hurts
your feet and I was only running on
pavement just that's just the route that
I had in Nashville and uh so yeah I had
no sand no Trails but I just figured
like neither does anyone else like I
have more consistency and and I I've
I've run every single day for so many
years that if we all have to recover the
next day I think I bet that I can
recover quick than them that was my like
assumption and that ended up playing out
but I didn't I wasn't confident that it
would I was just praying that it would
so the strategy being stick with the
leaders but remain just behind them like
you're like you're a lion tracker or
something right at some point though is
there like an inflection point where you
make a move or what changes so the first
day we're all together and with like
five miles to go we get to like the side
of a mountain and is just up straight up
and those the two the Swiss guy and the
Israeli guy get away from me and I'm
like holy [__] and when we get to the
top which reversing across the side of a
ridgel line but we're not on the top of
it we're on the side we're like if you
have a misstep I'm not exaggerating if
you have a misstep you're going to fall
down the mountain and this pack is so
heavy like if you get out of balance
you're going down so we get I get over
that they they're off the front like now
they're like a mile ahead of me and with
maybe a m two mile or two miles to go um
a really cool Italian journalist called
felipo orazi he's a huge Rich role fan
there was two Italians they filipo and
jeppi they loved you they were like call
Rich rooll call Rich rooll I'm like we
don't have reception and I would never
do that
so shout out to the Italian journalist
and um so he runs past me and I'm like
God I'm I'm like oh my God I'll be lucky
just to be in the top five like James
said holy [__] I'm I'm nervous now do we
get to like with less than a mile to go
we go through this like an old half
dried up River but it's like ankle deep
mud I fall down in the mud I'm like I am
a buffoon I I feel so stupid I've been
blown out I'm covered in mud and I limp
in and I got the vibe from those guys
cuz now like you know we've been we were
talking during the during the stage and
we had the morning and I think that
people are starting to recognize that
like I'm you know I'm someone to be uh
aware of and I get the vibe that they're
kind of like yeah that we taught them a
lesson kind of and if that isn't the
vibe that's what I'm telling myself
these guys think they got me on the
ropes but I'm like all right let's see
what happens tomorrow I'm going to be
much more
conservative so the next day is 28 miles
longest I've ever run and I just stay
conservative and I stay they the two the
Swiss and the Israeli guy get off the
front but I can see them and we get to a
couple Hills I get back on them I'm not
pushing in slowly and steadily I just
like pulled away from them with trying I
just stayed steady and uh with like 10K
to go I can't even see them behind me
I'm blowing them out and I slip and fall
in the strap on my backpack where it
attaches to the pack down at the bottom
rips off the backpack just rips and I
fall down and I bust my elbow open
unbeknownst to me so I get up in a in a
panic and I'm running holding this strap
with this pack which is super heavy and
my elbow's pouring blood but I don't
know I'm just Co I'm drenched in sweat
I'm caked in salt and uh Ian I'm running
in the desert right so I'm wiping the
blood which I think is sweat and I'm
touching my face and I'm when I finished
I'm covered in blood and they're like oh
my God what's wrong I'm like they go
what's wrong I'm like yeah look my
freaking backpack broke and they're like
no no no you're bleeding everywhere I'm
like no I'm not bleeding and they're
like no you're covered in blood I'm like
I'm definitely not bleeding I and I'm
like Oh my elbow's bleeding anyway I
clean it that's like some Apocalypse Now
[__] like Alien versus
Predator dude it was but then I was like
so what do you make of that though is
that the recovery kicking in your
ability to bounce back the next day like
those guys made you know put in a big
effort the day before I think they put
they couldn't sustain it yeah they put
in too big but but they were they they
weren't done like the Swiss guy wasn't
done everyone else lost time every day
but the Swiss guy was like a real
athlete like he was he was like a
mountaineer so like on the on the climbs
in the descents he was super efficient
like real good so that was day two day
three starts with I am not [__] you
like rock climbing like hands and knees
climbing up rocks dangerous like I'm
like how is everyone going to get up
this thing there's no way and uh the
Swiss guy within the first mile he's
gone I can't even see him I managed to
fix my bag with a I took a scalpa from
the doctor poked some holes in it and
put zip ties through and zip tied it
onto the bag 3 miles into stage three
they burst off so I it it was a it was
such a disaster but it was like a um
crisis management I took out the knife
that I was forced to carry cut the bag
pulled the strap through the the thick
part that goes down your chest and I
pulled it through and tied a knot and it
held miraculously and then after that
stage someone who dropped out gave me
their backpack and they took mine
so about 15 miles into that this is a 24
Mile stage about 15 miles and we get to
the sand dunes and I'm talking like just
imagine the loosest sand Beach you've
ever been to and you've got like six
miles to go and it's Hills so at one
point there's probably 200 yard like a
black diamond ski slope straight up I'm
on my hands and knees like in in the
sand like Navy SEAL stuff buried in sand
you're 10 miles a day is not preparing
you for something like that like all the
full body stuff dude like 10 people
dropped out at that sandun and they
could only rescue them with camels and
the camel couldn't get up that sand dun
so if you were up you had to slide back
down cuz the camel couldn't get up wow
so I get up to the top of it the Swiss
guys off the front I can't see them
behind me and I'm like I'm sand is
everywhere so much so that when I get
out of the sandune portion I have to
take off my shoes and socks and get this
sand out cuz it's like sandpaper and uh
I made some funny videos I showed your
guys that I'm going to give them that
they want to put into the video they're
real funny where I'm talking to the
camera like I'm in [__]
hell yeah we're [__] roughing it this
is adventure racing apparently my first
and last
one
that looks nice about to piss down rain
on our whole Camp I'm going to die this
is I can't believe I did this I'm never
doing this again so anyway I lost like
four minutes so at that point I'm 12
minutes down but I'm in second by 30
minutes and then the next day is the 50
mile stage and that's when like the race
got broken open and where I like
basically killed the guy and then saved
his life is that because it was less
technical that day or why were you able
to Gap him on that day when you were
behind the day before good question so
this day was just like slow and steady
wins the race it was just constant
undulation over fields and pastures and
up and down monstrous Hills and then the
Steeps were just as hard as the uphills
so about 12 or 15 miles in I'm listening
to music in one airpod and uh just to
keep my mind busy and I ran next to the
Swiss guys with us the three of us we
always start together but the Swiss guy
can tends to get dropped like a third to
halfway through so I run next to him and
I was like hey dudo did I tell you that
I [__] never get tired I feel so good
today like I think we might be able to
break a record within one mile I look
back and he's got his poles out walking
so so that was the moment that was when
the Israeli guy go now it's just me and
the leader and we're together from 15 to
30 and we're working together at this
point like there's so much camaraderie
now that I've almost abandoned racing
him I'm like let's just get through this
together we'll race another day cuz this
is like this is challenging we're in the
desert 50 Mi the checkpoints are like 6
to9 miles apart which is a long way so
you've got to get a shitload of water
which is heavy and um you know we're
we're getting through it so we're
walking the uphills we're pushing the
downhills we're pushing the flats and
around mile 30 we hit a checkpoint and
there's one more checkpoint around 43
maybe they were super spread up maybe it
was 35 so after that checkpoint we come
out of there in a little village and
we're running a flat he's like I got to
walk for a minute and I'm like okay I'm
going to walk with them like we're alone
in the desert there's like an element of
like danger too so it's not just like
I'm going to step on your neck now like
a marathon so I'm like all right I'll
walk with you let's let's go let's I
said let's walk to one flag we'll run to
two and let's just see if we can get
some life back so then he's like man I'm
low on Water I know [__] where's that
checkpoint and he's deteriorating fast
so now I'm giving him my water I'm
pouring water on his head I'm like look
on man just like get to that next
checkpoint and you'll be good you take a
rest so then very quickly he's like I
got to sit down and I'm like dude don't
sit please don't sit down give me a
backpack I'll I'll carry it and he's
like no no no I I can't let you do it
I'll get disqualified I'm like you want
to get disqualified or you want to die
like we're in no man's land and there's
no support vehicles and then so we're
going through is he sits down I'm trying
to shade him with my body I'm giving him
all my water and then a uh a support
vehicle eventually comes by I was so
pissed off I was like dude what the [__]
man someone's going to die die out here
like what are you guys doing the
checkpoints are so far away a [__]
camel can't make it that far without
water so they come and they get him so
they're tending to him and I take off
dude from four I think they got him
around 43 miles I put my head down and
drilled it from 43 to 50 fast to 7 Miles
of the whole race I think I ran and uh
got in there right at like 5:00 p.m. we
started at 8 so I think what's that 9
hours and um that's where I just blew it
open at that point I had like an 8 80
minute lead and then you get a little
bit of a
you're staring at 26 the next day and
you're like well that's my jam yeah I
was like Hey 90 minutes no one's beating
me like at this point now my confidence
was through the roof I'm like no one's
beating me I'm not giving away any
stages I'm winning everything so you end
up winning this race by 90 minutes yes
right first ever Ultra first of all what
was the sort of response to that amongst
this you know kind of clicky Ultra Trail
community of people who'd never heard of
you before with with the blank bio all
the people that by the end everyone's
super supportive cuz you're in it for a
week together but it was
like probably like a little bit mixed
emotions like damn it this guy came in
and beat us all at our own game a little
bit it wasn't like you know um when they
were giving out the awards for example
the the race director the woman's like
everyone comes up big hug oh great I
come up it's like cold Chan Shake
congratulations so I was like all right
cool see you but the response from our
community
and and in a weird way like I I
genuinely felt this the whole time I was
there like I felt a sense of community
with even people like yourself Rob Moore
my partner Teddy Atlas like I think
about all these things and again I was
telling you guys earlier a lot of times
the reality of a situation doesn't
really matter the only reality that
matters is your reality the story you
tell yourself so I'm telling myself yeah
I'm representing my people here all the
people that I've like know and trained
with and have trained with over the
years and have raced with and the people
that I'm friends with I'm like I'm
representing all of them a win for one a
win for one of us is a win for all of us
I really believe that and felt that cuz
I know when Dez Lindon won the Boston
Marathon like I was crying I was like oh
my God we did it I know that she's your
girl yeah but I was like so when I won I
was like yeah man I did it like in a
weird way I felt like I did this it was
a reflection of everyone I'm not I'm
just one person but I'm like a product
of the people that I'm around all the
time and I'm a product of the work that
I've done with these people and um but
no one more so than my family my family
has seen me do like win races and and
and do stuff that they're proud of but
nothing like this the response that they
got and that they gave me was
overwhelming like moved me to tears like
I came home there was science all over
the house the kids were just like plus
the kids are getting older I think they
realized the like magnitude and like how
shocking it was to others and to myself
like oh my God you I did this like I
still can't believe it wow but so that
part was just crazy like as an example
my wife never posts anything about me on
on Facebook or thing we're not the type
to be like yeah look at you know so
proud of my partner we just don't do
that and just just because we know how
we feel about each other but on this one
she posted a big thing on Facebook like
I'm so proud of my husband and I know
that she must have been like really
moved to post that so it was like it was
moving it was man I was it was beautiful
I mean congrats really quite something
that you went out there and conquered
that thing on your first time out it's
unbelievable it's it's just I was
telling you guys I was like I feel like
I'm talking about a third person like I
can't believe that guy did that I can't
believe I did it I'm so lucky I'm so
thankful and just it all paid off so I
want to get into the mindset a little
bit when you're in those low moments and
you're summoning you know that that like
urgency or that competitive spirit that
you have within you or you're think
thinking about your community and you
know how you're going to you know sort
of um represent them adequately to the
best of your ability like how do you
stay present with that or what are some
of the tools that you tap into to get
you through those low moments because in
an ultra in a 7-Day thing you're going
to have high highs you're going to feel
good you're going to feel like [__] you
know if you feel like [__] if you stick
with it that'll pass you'll start to
feel good again but how do you weather
those and you know really stay focused
on the large goal that you're trying to
achieve yeah no that's a great question
and and a lot of times we hear people
talk about mindset and all this kind of
stuff that can kind of sound cliche on
the surface unless you really like dig
deep into it and and I sincerely believe
that if you don't put yourself in
uncomfortable positions whether it's
starting a business learning an
instrument it doesn't have to be running
but if you never do anything
uncomfortable it's hard to get a lot to
get any growth there because the
pressure is not on I need a little bit
of pressure and and and kind of scrutiny
to kind of dig deep and I was like this
I couldn't think of something more
uncomfortable any one day event cool I
can show up and gut my way through it
seven days of camping and really having
to manage the food and manage the like
my like be responsible for my system my
sleep system and and everything
associated with it was like incredibly
intimidating and uncomfortable but
that's why did it I was like so freaking
scared that when I heard about the event
there was like I said that voice in my
head that was like man this is scary and
the other voice was like that's why
we're doing it and I know it's like I
don't want to sound cliche or like it's
hyper but it's the truth I was like holy
[__] that's scary [__] it let's do it
cuz if you don't like okay I won but if
I didn't show up and try I definitely
wouldn't win so it was kind of like who
who knows I mean who knows maybe if I
show up and do Leadville maybe I can win
that can I win badwater the one thing's
for sure if you don't get on the start
line no one you can't no one's going to
win are you going to make a
pronouncement right now about Leadville
I'm going to say West States badw I'm
going to say that you got your boy
Charlie on speed dial for your badwater
prep you might have to run a little bit
more than 10 miles a day to get ready
for that one I don't
know you know what's interesting is it's
one thing to go go from marathoning and
Elite marathoning at the level at which
you do it to step into an ultra most
people would start out with a 50k or a
50 mile um at a minimum they would enter
a race in which you have crew
support they're feeding you they're
taking care of you they're reading the
signs and you're always sort of being
held by a group of people uh who can
provide you know as much kind of morale
support as nutritional support uh but
you went you Sid stepped all of that did
a multi-day race your head's not hitting
the pillow at home after that thing each
night and all the mental space that you
have to devote to the logistics to the
food to all the tiny I mean this is one
of the things we talked about when we
talked like it's these tiny little
things that are easy to forget about
that can derail you you get one Blister
in the wrong place and like you're done
because you didn't you know make sure
that you put your socks on right or you
didn't tape your toes or or or or
whatever it is and it's just you and you
you got no one there to remind you about
any of that kind of stuff so how much of
that
experience um was devoted to you know
kind of the mental aspects of of the
logistics right because when you're
running a marathon it's like just you
just you got this your Tunnel Vision on
getting to that finish line and you
don't really have to worry about much
else there's Aid stations Etc um but
here you've got all these tactics that
are brand new to you
that can sort of Rob you of the mental
energy that you would normally devote to
just performance that's exactly why I
did it I know I can show up and be
competitive in a 50k or a 50 mile I know
I can and maybe someone listens like
[__] this guy he can't do it I know I
can be competitive I didn't know what I
could do here and I had been so long
since I felt nervous about attempting
something i' I always feel nervous about
hitting my goals but to feel nervous
about actually being able to complete
the event was a new level of nerves I
mean it was mad anxiety and to your
point Anything Could Happen dude every
day at the end of these stages people
would be in the medical tent their feet
look like they walked on hot coals and I
couldn't help but to walk over and be
like dude what the [__] have you done
any training how can your feet be like
that after the second day like how much
running have you done I mean if you've
been running you shouldn't have blister
like your feet are not blisters dude
skin gone Fe like their and all that
kind everything I I never seen you
didn't have any of those problems I had
a couple small blisters that were even
with the Gators you were able to keep
the sand out of
your sand would pour in and anytime it
got too heavy I just have to sit down
and pour it out quickly but the whole
time that I did this I kept that like
taurtis in the hair mentality where I'm
like I'm keeping moving I'm never
stopping I'm just if if I have to walk
I'll walk lower my heart rate and then
I'll Jog and then the backpack was such
a variable that I hadn't considered I
mean it the [__] out of my body I mean
every day I was like covered in road
rash like basically but to your point
there's a lot of mental energy that's
spent on making sure you're eating right
am I get enough calories do I have
enough like meal replacement bars to eat
during the during the stage CU
afterwards you know you're eating
freeze-dried food pretty pretty standard
you're just hungry a lot and I was
really focusing on hydration and fueling
during the stage and then afterwards I
was like [__] it I'm hungry I'll I'll
survive like it's not forever and I just
kept the other thing that I kept telling
myself that that sincerely work like we
talk about mindset again and it's easy
to gloss over it but I kept reminding
myself that I have the best life in the
world I'm the luckiest guy in the world
I have the [__] nicest kids I I've
created everything that I've Ever Wanted
myself I'm lucky I I'm so grateful and I
just kept saying this is temporary you
can take the easy way here and and look
for any excuse to get out of here my bag
ripped my elbows hurt I've got a blister
like or you can dig deep and it'll be
you'll be so much happier when you get
home and this is behind you and the
other thing I would remind myself when
it would get really hard and really hot
I would say yo Special Forces guys are
doing this every single day like it's
their job cuz it is and someone's trying
to kill them while they're doing it so
I'm like are you kidding me someone's
going to save me if I drop dead out here
or if I faint we're good and I would
just literally anytime I got that in
that negative space i' be like this is
easy in the grand scheme of Life
compared to what some people have been
through and the level of persecution I'm
like so I have to cover 28 miles or 50
miles today like this isn't this isn't
challenging I voluntarily IID for yeah
you didn't you're not being forced to do
this exactly right um which brings me to
this thought that I think we talked a
little bit about the first time which is
this unique sort of combination uh of of
different sensibilities that you have uh
on the one hand you have this incredible
certainty like you're like I'm going to
win I know I'm going to win you just you
go into these races with a level of
self-confidence and belief in your own
capacity and ability to outmatch the
best of them but on the other hand you
also have this this really genuine
humility like you are in awe of the
elites like the way that you talk about
Dez Linden or the other Elite
marathoners or or Cam yeah these yeah
cam our boy cam who just went up on the
Pod um yeah it's like you have a
reverence and a respect for the level at
which they execute their Craft um and
that's a
unique uh combination because usually
somebody who holds that kind of
reverence doesn't have that level of
self-confidence and and certainty that
you have so how do you like what is that
mix all about well I think that I'm a
realist like I know the difference
between me and professional runners is
far greater than the difference between
me and the next like level of amateur
athletes it's it's it's massive they're
on a pedestal they're like Miles Ahead
this is their job this is my hobby and I
love being the best that I can be but
I'm also very aware of the differences
between the elites and then the like
decent age group Runners like at the be
mile that I did in Chicago we'll talk
about in a minute I won the like quote
unquote celebrity
he in like I didn't know until I read
about it I thought you won the whole
thing and then I read the article on
outside like he didn't win the whole
thing you ran like 650 or something like
the guy who won it ran 430 and the guy
who won it sent me a beautiful DM
afterwards and I almost glossed over and
then I looked back and I was like oh my
God that's the guy who won I'm like dude
congratulations and he writes back dude
you killed it you're a legend I said
Legend I said you're a real Runner I'm
like the tallest short person and he's
like no no no everyone who runs is a
real Runner but he just couldn't have
been a nice guy but that was a perfect
example all El say how I think about it
is like I'm the tallest short person and
these guys I like The Killers I mean but
I will say I only ran 650 I wasn't
challenged I was drinking out of a can I
do think and it was the first time
athletic Brewing right it was it was an
NA beer NA beer but I will say that
knowing what I know now whether it was
real beer or na like I know that I could
be closer to six minutes with a little
bit of practice and again that not
wouldn't have been threatening anyone
but I was like this was
the drinking the beer part was harder
but the running was easier than I
thought it would be after 200 meters
halfway around the track you start to
like the the the the carbonation comes
up and you're like into a Groove but
then as soon as you get into the groove
you're like oh my God I got to chug
another beer so so it was the national
championships of the Beer Mile right it
was the uh Beer Mile World Championships
in Chicago sponsored by uh athletic
Brewing who sponsored me for the uh goby
race great guys awesome guys and um they
invited me out there to do that so I
erased uh NE Schulman who's a good
friend of mine who host never met but I
know who he is Shark Tank um catfish
catfish he's Casey's boy yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's how I met Casey through
Casey and I that through NE so uh Carl
and I he's he's a really good runner
really good yeah uh Carlin Isles who's
like the fastest rugby player in the
world two-time Olympian this guy ran
like a
47400 in in in when he was competing in
track like elite elite Sprints are like
101 700
like Elite so I was like this guy's
going to blow me out and I walk Under
the Tent where where before the event
he's like oh here he comes he has the
Champs guy's gonna kill everyone I'm
like is he talking about me this is like
a real athlete like this guy's gonna
kill me uh and and Cynthia uh Cynthia
from uh NFL Networks she does this she's
a statistician in NFL Networks and uh
Darren roel uh the business reporter
Sports business reporter and um Francis
Ellis from Barcelo Sports who's
hilarious really funny guy went to
Harvard uh and yeah they just it it
wasn't very competitive but it was a fun
time the people couldn't have been nicer
it was like it was such a um nice break
after the goby race to go there and just
like the people were so kind to me I was
so I never felt so much gratitude and my
wife came with me first time she's ever
come to any race we got a babysitter she
came and she was just like wow a lot of
people there knew who you were I was
like I it's crazy isn't it I'm like I
can't believe it you're getting a lot
you're getting a lot of ink lately buddy
Wall Street Journal New York Times
you're having a moment it's crazy isn't
it the craziest thing of all that my
friend uh Nate cze at ran apparel he
introduced me to a dude named Brent
Montgomery who I've become very good
friends with and Brent is the head of
wheelhouse Productions big production
company they produce alone Duck Dynasty
Pawn Stars intervention like they're
legit they have some huge TV shows and
uh we're working on a couple TV show
Concepts right now in conjunction with a
couple networks that and we're like
right on the finish line and if one of
them gets done man I might be hosting a
Prime Time network TV show yeah Dre you
shared with me a little bit about that
are you allowed to talk about what those
concepts are or you keep what I've just
said so you know coming to television
set soon can write out along the lines
of prison something SS it's it's
something you were born to do it's it's
like a dream come true if it gets made
it would be too good to be true I don't
know that if my body could handle so
much much gratitude wow um in reflecting
now it's been what has it been like
three or four weeks since the goby thing
two weeks two it's only been two weeks
wow um thinking back on that
experience what did you learn about not
just yourself but also
about preparing for and running an ultra
that you wish you knew going into
it the things that I wish I knew would
just small technical like technical
aspects about how to get lighter how to
be a little bit more proficient with the
pack
um but honestly I would say like I said
earlier like until you show up and try
something you just don't know a lot of
people I think that there are a lot of
people out there that can do a lot of
things but they don't have the guts to
get on the start line and it does take a
lot of guts to commit to something like
that I mean dude even flying imagine
you're on like a 20-hour flight to Korea
and the whole time I'm like what am I
doing there isn't a single ounce of
Happiness the whole time it's just dread
like and I was like I have to get out of
this mindset but I was also like okay as
soon as this thing starts we'll start to
get into a rhythm but it was like super
nervous anxious feeling of just let's
just start let's just start it's like
you know showing up at the Boston
Marathon three hours before the race
starts you're like just shoot the gun
let's do this I don't like the
anticipation um by contrast to flight
home I was on Cloud9 I was like oh I'm
so happy I did it I can't believe it I
mean you went into it with a with a
level of confidence and certitude that
at a minimum you were going to complete
this thing but when I look at it I think
what I take from your experience making
that leap from marathoning into a
multi-day race is proof positive that
we're all capable of so much more than
we allow ourselves to believe and and
you fertilized a little seed of of
belief and then you tested yourself at a
at at a at a at an adventure that
probably a lot of people said like not
so fast buddy like maybe start over here
you don't have to go all the way over
here uh and coming out the other side
Victory aside just to understand like
wow like I actually did that I put
myself on the line I did I did something
I was scared to do I was uncomfortable
about it the entire time um and I Pro
something to myself and you know if we
can all Flex that a little bit more in
our lives not just just in sport but in
all facets of our life uh I think we you
know we all kind of come out the other
side better people more robust people
with a capacity for perseverance and I
know that's a big topic for you right
like how do you think about perseverance
yeah I'm actually working on a a speech
I've I've been lucky enough in the last
year or two to give a few speeches to
schools and uh companies and I'm working
on a speech now about the practice of
perseverance of actually putting
yourself in positions intentionally that
are super challenging and like I said it
could be anything maybe it's like taking
Jiu-Jitsu uh like that's something right
now that's like on my list where I'm
like man I'm so freaking nervous to go
sign up for Jiu-Jitsu I've taken classes
before but my youngest son dude he's a
killer he's seven years old like he's
Ragdoll in 12-year-old kids it's I have
four kids I signed three I signed all
four up three of them quit could they
didn't want it understandably the little
one it's like a dad's dream come true I
watch him and I'm like I cannot believe
what he's doing I cannot believe he's
adapting and adjusting this quickly he's
choking guys arming guys I'm like oh my
God he's a killer but of all my kids
he's the nicest so anyway back he's a
little one is he the one that that gets
the Mohawk haircut every year has to
have it down this year he's like that
down to the skin down to the skin and
I'm like Mom's going to kill us he's
like I want it and I'm like all right
soon as school's over but um yeah so
I've been working on this concept of the
practice of perseverance like I said
it's just it's just putting yourself in
a position where the only way you're
getting through is to persevere maybe
it's writing a book maybe it's learning
the piano but we all have things that we
wish we did or we wish we could do and I
say maybe you want to [__] learn how
to ride a skateboard in a ramp like I'd
love to do that but I'm like H do I
really want to bust my ass 20 times to
learn although it does look fun if you
can learn how to do it kite surfing o
I'd love to do that looks so much fun
but do I really want to go down and go
through the whole learning process but
this is a perfect example with the kids
so my youngest and my oldest so the
youngest is doing Jiu-Jitsu the youngest
and the oldest went down and started
wrestling and they went with an elite
wrestling team where I was like guys
before we went and I said guys
listen if you're not willing to be the
worst and to be terrible you'll never be
the best because when Mike Tyson went
into a boxing gym the first time he was
terrible and if he wasn't willing to get
beat up he couldn't have become what he
became and that goes for any fighter and
any wrestler anything you do if you're
not willing to stink initially you can't
get to the next level because if you
could show up and be awesome on day one
then what the [__] would you want to be
the best at it for if anyone can show up
and be awesome the point of having
something that's important to you and an
accomplishment is that it took
perseverance and wrestling is is a
perfect example so we went down the
people were super kind they were the
kids were nasty good I mean at one point
they're warming up and the guy's like
all right guys cartwheels forward rolls
back rolls all right guys back hands
Springs I'm like back hands Springs
someone's going to break their neck a
bunch of kids just guys stop back hands
springing that so my some of the kids
just did like a back roll and popped up
my little one flips right over I'm like
H you know how to do a back handspring
he's like no I just made it up wow but I
mean that's that's the way he is that's
the the point is like if you can't
persevere through some discomfort you
can't get to like the promis line you
can't get to the top of the mountain
unless you're willing to persevere up to
like hot middle section where you like
question and you like decision and I I
believe that you can practice that
ability to persevere through anything
and this to me was a lesson to myself
like yeah this sucks I don't know if I
can do this I have never run in the
desert like I said I never slept in a
tent the whole thing overwhelmed me but
I was like [__] it I'm doing this it's
like jumping in the ocean and being like
hey I got to swim to that Island over
there well the only way I'm going to get
there is if I jump in and start so I
just that that that's the whole concept
is like finding things that intimidate
you and scare you and figuring out can
you do it and if you don't do it what
can I learn what can I do differently
what can I do to go back and fix this
when I think about perseverance I think
about growth mindset versus fixed
mindset which is basically what you just
laid out right are you willing to look
bad in front of other people are you
willing to not be great at something and
like liberate yourself from whatever
narrative you tell yourself about where
you're at right you need that in order
to grow but beyond that perseverance
requires a capacity to suffer a stick
tutiven like a sense of belief in
yourself to get you through hard times
that comes with experience of
continually putting yourself in those
situations um and just a you know an
overall
capacity to weather grit right and I
often wonder how much of that is
god-given you come out of the womb or
through the various experiences that you
have as a young person that gets
instilled into you or whether that's
something that you can develop can you
go from somebody who has a fixed mindset
to a growth mindset can you be somebody
who is fearful and um not somebody who's
you know putting themselves in difficult
situations and and over time develop
that grittiness that ability to
persevere like how much of this is
innate versus something that you can
learn and develop I do believe that some
people are born with the Killer Instinct
that they're like I'm doing everything
life's in amusement park I'm riding
every ride and there's other people who
are like I'm sticking on the ferris
wheel it's like I know what I'm getting
and it's cool and that's fine but I
think for the people that want to
develop that mindset that it's
100% achievable and it doesn't have to
start with something as crazy as like
going across the desert but it might
start with like signing up for a 5k for
someone who's never run a mile and just
being like I'm setting some goals I do
believe that it becomes contagious it's
like losing weight or getting over drugs
it's like you start to build momentum
with a little bit of longevity behind
you with sobriety with weight loss you
start to see the results and you're like
oh [__] I I might be able to do this but
nothing changes unless something changes
you have to take the first step and like
be willing to get uncomfortable and I
always think man when I'm feeling super
comfortable and things are so good even
my wife would be like dude we're at the
beach just sit and chill I'm like I feel
like I'm wasting time I do think that
there is a important component about
being able to relax and uh unplug and
decompress 100% I I don't do it well but
I do know that that's something that
I've got to work on but that's the
mindset that I've developed is like man
it's life is short and especially as
I've like turned 50 I'm like oh my God
I'm on the back half man I got to make
sure I get everything in within reason
and um actually the last time I was here
when you uh my wife listened to the
interview and she's like man that guy
Rich he's a mastermind he could be a
psychologist he's like PhD in Psychology
I'm like what do you mean she's like
when he was asking you about um do you
think your running has become a new
addiction and could be like maybe an
issue or something to that effect I was
like yeah 100% I'm I'm super aware of
that and and very cognitive of that and
I've thought a lot about it since then
and trying to find balance and it's
funny because after you after we did
that interview and I thought a lot about
that I went to a um a place called uh
onsite Workshop which is a trauma
Healing Center there's one in uh
Nashville and one in uh SoCal and uh it
was like lifechanging for me it was in
what way they Bas you know I didn't
think I had any trauma in my life I was
like I had a traumatic childhood I mean
not relatively speaking not that bad oh
come on yeah so they they pulled the
covers on that one quick I I would
imagine D I was in one-on-one intensive
therapy for like five or six hours a day
with a psychologist that was like by the
end I was like you're a [__]
Mastermind you're a genius like you saw
right through me she was literally like
she just picked everything apart all the
things that I thought I was so confident
about she was like is that really true
and I was was like dude I cried more in
that week than I've cried in my life she
would put the we had it was very
interactive which you know on the
surface I'm like I don't want to do all
this Hocus Pocus [__] but by the end I
was like what else do you got for me
tell me what else [__] paint rocks
I'll do it let's keep going so she puts
up all the stuff on the uh wall you know
like about your childhood and who are
these characters identify and we're
going through it and so she's talking
and then after a day or two she's like
look up on the wallet like what you
reflected on as your childhood you know
she's like who would this person be I'm
like fire breathing dragon she's like
okay so she's like do you think that in
hindsight do you think you've had trauma
there and I'm like I'm like a a crying
mess I'm like I can't believe this and
it just it gave me my home life and my
relationship with my wife and my
children has never been better as a
result because I was like I was almost
trying to force my like my beliefs or my
my
way of doing things on the children
versus like
being
amenable to what if if nothing else what
my wife suggests my wife grew up in the
most healthy environment loving family
my wife is like the baby Whisperer she
is like she's what I am to running she's
that times 10 to being appar parent
she's just awesome at it that's all she
ever wanted to be she's good at it so
what I realized in this is like she
knows some of this stuff I don't know it
it gave me
pause and and showed me how to like take
a deep breath and like not be afraid to
let to give up some of the control and
it get it more than anything taught me
patience with the kids so like as an
example I'd be recording the podcast
they'd be in the in the theater
underneath my office jumping around
playing music and I'd go down there
typically i' be like guys hold on guys
what are you doing how many times I got
to tell you I'm recording it's only an
hour a week cut the crap instead I go
guys hey I'm sorry hey I'm recording man
if you guys could just keep it down
there like Dad so sorry we're going to
go outside and I was like oh my God that
was
magic what a difference it seems like
such a small thing but that's actually a
big deal but to get to that point I had
to do some work you couldn't just tell
me like try this I had to understand the
like
the the kind of ramifications behind it
and like why would I try that and when
you understand she's like would you want
to ever make your children feel the way
you felt and I was like again a mess I
was like I i' would rather be dead I
would never want my children to feel
like that and it's not that I'm not firm
with them I was just too firm so finding
that balance of like firm and like
tenderness was critical and and and
honestly part of the reason where I
committed to doing this was because of
the conversation we had and just
reflecting on like just going out and
fogging myself and trying to be the best
at running doesn't take away the work
that has to be done behind the scenes
and and and the impact that I'm having
on my own children and you know we I
think that it's easy to forget that
children especially young children like
what my children were and are is their
first memory you think about your first
memory your first experience with a
roller coaster with an airplane it's
it's it's etched in your mind forever
whereas you and I could go on 20 flights
a year and not remember any of them but
you remember the first one and all of
their experiences a first- Time
experiences and like it's my job to make
sure that they're as positive as
possible not like I remember the time I
went to the beach with my dad and I he I
ordered the wrong sandwich and then he
got mad and threw it in the trash right
which is which is something you might
have done in an off-handed way and
forgot about and had no sense that
that's getting deeply embedded in that
kid's brain and 30 years later they're
going to be thinking about that cuz my
parents did that [__] to me and when I
was there at that Center doing this like
deep dive into like my own mental health
I was like oh my God that's exactly what
happened to me and I was like oh my God
how do I undo what I've already done
wrong and she's like no no you don't
have to worry about that just go home
and be the best version of yourself and
like they'll understand that people make
mistakes so like as an
example my youngest son he's in
Jiu-Jitsu last week he goes on Fridays
it's really competitive like competition
Jiu-Jitsu and a kids from out of town
who's like 11 he's seven and the kid's
like three belts higher than him when
he's training for a tournament he's so
much more experience it's like a almost
like a teenager rolling with them most
kids that are that much better even in
boxing and wrestling they know when
they're outmatched and they take it easy
on the little kid this kid beat the [__]
out of my son for 30 minutes it was so
hard to watch and I was getting pissed
at the coach cuz I'm like look you're
going to get him demoralized at some
point but Cameron kept fighting kept
fighting and at some point he was kind
of given a halfast effort and I couldn't
help myself I'm like Cameron come on and
he lost it he started crying and it was
I was mortified I was I was crushed I
was like dude I'm so sorry and I was
like man I get I get emotional thinking
about it
now cuz I had to like own that and take
responsibility and it and [__] Monday
he's like Dad let's go Jiu-Jitsu we got
to get ready and I was hoping that I
didn't want to be like hey we got
Jiu-Jitsu and then the coaches were like
Cameron good for you cuz they were like
I mean he got the [__] kicked out of him
and he kept fighting and I just was like
I wasn't I think I was as much yelling
at the coach as I was at him like come
on man what are we doing the kid's
getting the [__] kicked out of me and
he's not trying anymore like this is
counterproductive and I think we all
learned the lesson there but I was like
I'm never ever offering coaching again
at any kids sport I'll walk outside I
don't want to be that parent living
vicariously through my kids which is why
I have my own things going on I don't
want to be that guy but valuable lesson
and painful but
necessary well first of all massive
credit to you for for you know even
signing up to go into that kind of
trauma work I think it's super important
uh it's clear as day to me when I look
at your backstory and the things that
you lived through that you know your
past is littered with traumatic
experiences that until you start to
excavate you don't understand the extent
to which they're controlling your life
unconsciously and as somebody who grew
up in a chaotic situation it's no
surprise that you're going to want to be
a control freak you know control the
variables and be in control of all the
kind of aspects of your life from
business to running Etc um and and with
that comes a sense that this is how you
survive like this is how you live like
it's well-intentioned it's a defense
mechanism it's a survival tactic right
and there's no reason to believe because
you're successful on the outside that
this is problematic until you start to
look into it and you realize the extent
to which you're living your life
unconsciously repeating patterns that
you inherited or that you developed as a
means to survive a very difficult
situation and then comes the revelation
of letting go of those and trying
something different now you can have the
most capacious growth mindset of all
time but undoing that hardware and
rewiring is one of the most difficult
things you're ever going to do because
because I'm sure and I'm interested in
your thoughts on this what comes up is
hey if I let go this this is how I do
everything in the world if I let go of
that all the good things in my life go
away I don't know how to function in the
world anymore yep that's one of the
scary I mean you can talk about being
scared to go out for seven days in the
desert but that's life-threatening 100%
the the work that I had to do at onsite
was 10 times scarier than going to the
desert when I was driving to that place
I was like driving to like a life
sentence I was like driving to jail I
again what was the instigating inci was
it did something happen like what
convinced you that you should go do that
honestly I think I think one of the big
turning points was like listening to
this interview back and listening to
myself like realizing how dependent I
was on achievements and accomplishments
and running and like all the
extracurricular stuff to validate myself
and thinking about that and my
relationship with my wife was terrible I
was just like a monster I was trying to
control everything trying to like just
do too many things
and honestly I think my relationship was
in such turmoil with my wife that I was
like desperate for help to fix it cuz I
knew that I'm the problem and um my
friend who I bought my house from in
Tennessee he had gone there and it was
expensive I maybe it was like 10 grand
for like 4 days which to me is expensive
and but at the same time I'm like not
too like how much is your life worth and
uh I called him up day I was looking at
it looking at it I knew I needed to do
[__] I knew I needed therapy but to me
going once a week to therapy would be
like putting your finger in a damn
that's about to crack in the dam and the
Dam's about to break like hey once a
week ain't going to help me I need like
heavy artillery like like when I talk to
you about the ultra I was like Hey
when's the soonest I can get into on
site they were like then and next thing
you know I was like oh my god what have
I done just like with the GOI desert I
was like dude it was crazy I drive up
there and I didn't know any like the GOI
desert I didn't know what I didn't know
and with the onsite I didn't even care
to research it I was just like I'm just
going get there didn't know if I could
keep my phone or not didn't know
anything they were like yep phone
phone's gone I hadn't put on like email
alerts like hey I'm off the grid for
four or five days whatever it was I
think it was 5 days and then they're
like okay here's your cabin you're in
that cabin over there I'm like do I have
my own room cuz I I requested my own
room and they're like no you know you
have roommates I'm like roommates I'm
like oh my god what the I get in 50 I'm
a grown ass man man there's three beds I
had the calendar up taped up on my wall
with all the sessions and I'd X them off
like we were in jail I'm like dude one
more session down we're almost out of
here I go guys we're halfway done let's
go celebrate I'll buy Cokes for everyone
but there wasn't even soda there you
know it was all everything was
controlled um but yeah it was just a lot
of hard work and uh like I said I didn't
know anything and man like I said I I
sound like a big baby I spent more time
crying and then just driving home and
like apologizing to my wife and one of
the things that I realized when I was
there is that that the woman pointed out
to me she's like you know you've like
given your wife every reason in the
world to like ditch you like you've
almost dared her to leave you almost
because you're afraid of doing this work
it seems like and you have to recognize
how strong she is to put up with the
[__] that she's put up with and
stick with it because she's so desperate
to hold her own family together and that
was like that's heavy [__] heavy and
I was like I couldn't apologize enough
and it was like game changer for us and
listen there's obviously there's bumps
in R there there's there's there's
hiccups in every relationship we have
you know arguments about petty [__]
now but it's in perspective now because
usually I'm always the bad guy so now
when she's out of line I could be like
man you really being a jerk to me and
she's like you're right you're right I'm
sorry but it's given us um I don't know
it's given us a breath of fresh air with
regards to our um our personal
relationship with each other and the way
we deal with the children it's was Earth
shattering in from my huge from a from a
parenting perspective this is something
I talked about with Peter AA when he was
here as well because I did a similar
type experience in December and it was
revelatory and you realize the extent to
which despite your best efforts to not
parent in the unhealthy ways in which
you were parented when you're under
stress or duress you will default to
doing those very things that you
promised you would never do right and
then you have the shame and the
guilt and when you go through this
process and you wrestle with those
demons and you really unearth all that
[__] [__] and you work through it you
understand that you have the power and
the ability and the capacity to arrest
that pattern that's probably been going
on for Generation after generation after
generation and you have the opportunity
to tell a new story and to pass on to
your kids through the way that you
parent and Mentor them a new way of
being so that that pattern which your
whole life you've just thought this is
who I am because of who I came from
stops here yep and that's the greatest
gift that you can give to your kids and
I don't care who you are how successful
you are what what kind of amazing
healthy family you came from we all have
[__] man we all have stuff that happened
to us and that gets imprinted in our
brains and shows up in behaviors that we
wish we could stop
perpetuating and yet find ourselves
powerless to do so unless we really hit
pause and go deep like you did and I
think it's massive that you made that
investment not just in yourself but
really in your family and in future
Generations yet to be born yeah because
look at the end of the day I would die
for my kids like and so if I was willing
to die for these guys the least I can do
is put my own ego aside and be the
person that I know I can and need to be
and to your point the guilt and the
shame the cycle of guilt and shame is
like so powerful that I hadn't thought
about it in those terms until I had done
the work at onsite and I was like holy
[__] I'm riddled with guilt and shame
not just at the way I might behave dayto
day but like carrying that addiction
Journey with me and like the the the the
the pain that that caused me long term
it's like prior to that happening I was
like really happy positive dude I was
like a good kid the principal at high
school liked me all the teachers and I
mean they still would but I didn't like
I I liked myself and then after going
through that I was like what a [__]
loser you are how could you possibly do
this like you're the you're as bad as
anyone else or you're junky and getting
over that has been has not been easy the
like getting off the drugs the physical
the physical act of abusing drugs is one
thing but getting over that
the the damage that I did to my own ego
and to my own personality is has been
very difficult cuz in like it's kind of
like what I said when when I was in
Chicago I was like oh these people know
you there's a part of me still that's
like man these people really like me I
don't even [__] like myself some of
the time you know and that's the part
that I'm so grateful for I'm like man I
it it gives me pause it makes me think
like man you have to show yourself some
compassion at times and I that's one of
the things that I've struggled with the
most is showing myself Grace towards
myself I I'm just so hard on myself
internal Peter AA described it perfectly
if I [__] was late for something I'd
be like you [__] idiot how could you
be late for this versus like hey man
roll with it it's just [__] happens like
because if if that happened to if the
things that happen to me happened to
someone else I'd be like dude chill man
everyone makes a mistake don't even
worry about I'd be the best cheerleader
yeah you would never you would never
treat another person the way that you
treat
so so you have this outward
facing um self-belief and confidence but
inward a lot of that is being funneled
through this self-deprecating loathsome
you know perspective of who you are and
then of course that gets channeled into
your running right what is the
relationship between your running and
all of those wounds like if you feel
like you're a piece of [__] how much of
the suffering and the training
and the racing is really about punishing
yourself because you feel like you don't
deserve good things or the only way that
you can possibly contend with the guilt
and the shame is to is to just create
physical pain for yourself as almost
like you know like like a like a
hairshirt or like being just being
[__] you know yeah whipped by the
priest or something like that right and
then you can feel okay because you've
done your Penance and I think
the question that I asked you in the
first podcast that I guess on some level
you know kind of led to you going to
this place I'm not taking credit for
that but no no it absolutely did you
know began to you get you asking
questions the question as I recall that
I asked you was who's Ken R out without
running if you woke up tomorrow and
running's off the table you couldn't do
it anymore you couldn't compete you
couldn't push yourself physically who's
Ken write out and and you know that led
to an interesting discussion but now I'm
curious about how you would answer that
now having had the experience that you
just had funny the first thing that
comes to my mind is who's Ken rer I was
think say like I'm a dog I don't if it's
not running maybe it's maybe it's
nothing to do with physical maybe I'll
start some kind of business that I'm
incredibly passionate about I just
haven't found that opportunity yet but I
would Channel all the same energy into
something to be you know to show myself
that I can like overachieve and like
grind at something right but what's
beneath that what's what's what's
motivating that insane you know engine
that you have to be the best or you have
to overachieve is it insecurity is it
fear is it a sense that if you don't do
that that you're a piece of [__] or
you're worthless like there's there's
there's very laudable aspects of that
trait yep but there's also these darker
kind of pieces here right that are that
are unhealthy and and you'll be
successful everyone will tell you you
know you did a great job but then you go
home and it's a [__] show right because
because the unhealthy pieces are the
ones that are kind of dictating your
behavior in a way that you wish weren't
happening yeah I I don't mean to be like
project that's the case for you that's
an excellent question and I think one
that everyone can benefit from if
nothing else the thought-provoking
nature is that that's a good point like
my one of my biggest fears in the world
and I've told my wife this from the day
we met I'm like I'm so afraid of being
mediocre at anything why I don't know
like it's obviously it's some of it is
insecurity and um self-consciousness but
I just when I that's the great
discomfort right like you want to put
yourself in a dis in an uncomfortable
situation for you go into something and
say I'm just going to be okay at this I
just want to finish yeah i'mna
participate and and hold yourself back
yeah just just to like check your ego
then I'd be that's harder then I'd be
like the clown in the group I'd be like
come on guys let's have fun if I'm not
trying to win I'm like trying to make it
as enjoyable as possible I don't know
it's like maybe it's like the addict in
me is like constantly needs that
dopamine release either it's from trying
to overachieve or from trying to have
fun I I don't know but that's definitely
like something that I've spent a lot of
time thinking about and you know I hate
feeling like I have to perform for the
um attention or affection of others but
there certainly an element of that and I
almost wonder like if other people that
have had success at anything and again
not to try to hold myself up on a
pedestal like some professional athletes
but I wonder if a guy like cam morf
feels that or Dez feels that thing of
like you know what's driving me to do
this what like what what what would
happen if I couldn't do this anymore I
wonder how other people would answer
that because I'm not sure but I know
that the thought of just like being
mediocre at at anything is like
scary to me I don't want to go through
my whole life and be like yeah oh
there's Ken R yeah he was there who else
was there oh this guy was there we
didn't really hear anything from him but
he was there I like what what the hell
man I you know but but maybe when I was
running in Mongolia I see the people I
was talking to one of the guys the Swiss
guy as were're running and I said man
these guys are living out here on these
fields herders we're in no man's land
and I said dude I bet you that those
guys are happier than us they must love
this otherwise they' go do something
else maybe they mve to UL bat made the
city and you know open a hotel or
something but they're out there and they
just seemed completely happy so I often
wonder like who's winning the guy who's
just living content life in like you
know farming uh coffee beans in Hawaii
or the guy who's making $20 million
working in finance in New York I can
guarantee it's not the guy in New York
that [__] job I'd rather be dead like
no amount of money is worth that kind of
like anxiety and stress and keeping up
with the Joneses and like worrying about
what suit you're wearing and watch
you're wearing it's just g g that's my
motivation in life to try to do
something different so I never have to
go back to that yeah but you got your
foot in the business World in more than
a small way right like how what is the
relationship between all of these
mindset tools and your
competitiveness how do these things play
off of each other like what have you
learned from your marathoning your
experience doing this Ultra your success
as an athlete that spills over to
business and and vice versa yeah I know
good question when I was um prior to
getting into Endurance Sports when I was
just a Salesman in um on a trading desk
you know it was just constantly trying
to be nice to guys that I didn't like
having them be like completely
disrespectful to me all the time and any
sales guys and financial sales guys
listening to this will relate it's just
a terrible terrible existence and uh you
know you have a few good relationships
and you make a lot of money but like
your life or your your financial
security lives and dies with those
relationships and it's stressful but
now when I've when I've done some things
that like have garnered attention and
I've I I don't think it's just winning I
think it's also the way I've carried
myself and the sincere humility that
with which I feel after these events I I
think it's been um it's almost been
attractive to people in the space so
that people who are into running so now
I've been you know for the Last 5 Years
roughly I've worked as a placement agent
so I'll help Brands like um Roa for
instance I didn't work with them or rone
the apparel company like again I didn't
work with them but those are the kind of
Brands I might work with them to help
them raise like a series a or series B
and I have Institutional Investor
relationships and coincidentally the
best relationships I have with some of
these guys other the people that are
into running and um I have some
excellent Rel relationship with people
that I genuinely like really enjoy being
around like the nice thing about doing
this freelance work is with there's
someone that I don't like unlike my
previous life I don't have to deal with
them moving on there's too many like
there's too many other opportunities to
focus on negativity and um as a result
I've kind of surrounded myself with
like-minded people that are all into the
same thing so and and I've been very
lucky that I worked on a few deals that
worked early on one of them was a
company called power dot that was
acquired by theab Body I invested in
that early in a convertible note and I
put a bunch of buddies into it and with
a convertible note if the company gets
acquired before the note converts to
equity you get paid a multiple of the
money and within six months of the
investment it got acquired so as a
result we all got multiple on our money
and all the guys involved were like
what's next so now I only work on deals
that I invest in and when I do invest
and I bring it to like this my little
network of high net worth individuals
family office offes or even some
institutions they're you know they're
like are you investing cool okay we're
at least in but we'll decide the amount
send us all the materials we'll do the
diligence and it's like I've been super
lucky that I've created this I say to my
wife all the time I'm like can you
believe that I've been able to do this I
don't have a job I don't work this is
unbelievable CU I like doing this it's
completely different than the tradeing
desk environment and that like kind of
Hardcore banking where it's more like
this is very much based on relationships
and um it's been wonderful like Brands
reach out if I think that it's something
I would invest in and I can do usually
it gets done I've had very few failures
in that space and um luckily because
I've picked them strategically and uh
but yeah so so so the the running has
complemented it really well because most
of the brands that I would work with are
in kind of like human performance or um
health and wellness space like no one's
coming for me no one's asking me to help
them raise a software as a service
business I just it's not my wheelhouse I
don't do Tech I'm just that's way above
my uh intellectual pay grade you're when
I look at you I see a people guy you're
a relationships guy to your to your
point um and you're somebody who
innately understands people I think the
word like networking or networker is a
terrible pejorative but like I think
that you like you're you're on the phone
you're talking to people all the time
you know what people want you know what
people need you make sure that people's
needs are met you're one of those guys
who's got a guy for everything if I
needed something like I need this I'll
call Ken he's like I got a guy need a
gun need some money tell me what you
need you got the guy right of course um
how do you become the guy who's always
got a guy that's a good question and I
talked about this the last I was on here
about networking if you think you're
networking strike one no this isn't like
something that you consciously do it's
the way you live your life and please
for the love of Jesus last time I was on
here I said I hate LinkedIn I don't
understand why people send LinkedIn to
strangers without even an explanation
like hey here's why I want to connect
with you I go through this whole rant
the last time I get home I am not
[__] you I had like two or 300
LinkedIn requests please if you don't
tell me why you want to connect why
would I want to have an anonymous you
reply to every one of them telling them
why you weren't going to accept no I'm
sorry if you don't get a yes from me
immediately I see them all if I H ignore
it's because there's no explanation and
what good is a Rel what good is it to
say I'm connected to Ken if we don't
know each other and if someone asked me
do you know Steve Smith no I don't know
that guy well you're connected to him on
LinkedIn how do he slip through the
cracks goodbye but um yeah but to your
point it's like I used to I I said to
Rob more uh maybe about a year or two
ago I said you know I think that one of
my biggest one of my best most
marketable skills is being interesting
he said no I disagree I think that
you're not as interesting as you are
interested you are really interested in
people like when you know he's like I've
been with you a million times where
someone like talks to us and you ask
them a million questions about what
they're doing but it's not conscious but
I am interested like I'm interested in
what people have to say and what they
have to do but it's one extreme or the
other like Rob was telling me when we
were running this morning he was like
yes so and so was asking like so what's
the deal with Ken and and he said that's
a transparent guy like what you see is
what you get and if he doesn't like you
unfortunately he doesn't do a good job
of hiding it
and I think that that's the truth is
like people either love me or hate me
and I I'm aware of that I don't want
people to hate me but at the same time
if you hate me it's probably because I
hate you I don't hide that and I don't
like something about someone and I I
have a hard time like hiding contempt
and that's a fault of my own because I
don't want to hurt anyone's feelings I
want to be kind to everyone I I really
do but there's some people that you're
just not going to like and I know that
when you have a big personality which I
can at times that it sometimes is
off-putting to others I I don't I
certainly don't want people to dislike
me but I understand that that's I'm not
for everyone but more people than not I
think kind of see through that and
recognize that the people who are my
friends I'll help them do anything if I
have $100 and you need 90 like cool
we'll figure out a way to get the 90
back but here it is and that's I hope
and think that most of my friends would
agree with that assessment that that's
how I feel towards them the people that
are in my life I I I like I said earlier
I'm a product of the people I'm around
I'm so grateful for the friendships I've
had that I have right now like when I
was working in finance I was like an
empty vessel which is why I turned to
drugs I I I couldn't feel this void of
emptiness that I had and the people that
I was working with not all of them there
were some beautiful people but there
were a lot of complete [__] and I
just I I wasn't good in in that
environment it was like I was like a
tree that didn't like a palm tree trying
to grow in [__] Staten Island it
sucked it was miserable I didn't really
fit in with everyone there I just For
Better or Worse um and now like I said I
if someone's doesn't jive with me or
doesn't fit with my beliefs I don't have
to deal with them and I I say to my wife
all the time I've never been in a
position in my life ever where I've had
less conflict with people I never have
conflict with people ever like on a on a
working basis you know you might have
work with someone off the cuff in the
subway of something um which my wife
would be like why do you have words with
someone in the subway I'm like ah
sometimes I just can't let [__] go when
I see wrongs I got to speak up yeah like
you chiming in in comment threads on
Instagram too I try not to unless
someone's negative I hope that's
improved since the last time we talked
yeah I very rarely respond to negative
comments anymore yeah when I look at
your life I see I see someone who's
living a pretty aspirational life like
you get to do what you want you get to
make money in the way that you want you
get to you know pursue your athletic
adventures and you know distinguish
yourself in that world you get to be a
parent to these kids that you love so I
would imagine
people want to know or come up to you
and ask like how do I like how do I
craft or cultivate this type of life
like do I follow my passion do I do the
right thing Etc and when I reflect on my
own life I can't help but think about
the role that pain has played in getting
me to change or getting me to kind of
wake up to you know ways that aren't
serving me and and and kind of
compelling me because I was so [__]
backed into a corner to finally pay
attention and start to kind of make some
shifts or whatever that have led me to
this place so how do you think about the
role that suffering and pain has played
and and helping you get to where you're
at and is it possible to arrive at a
place like that without having to
weather all the suffering yeah well for
starters I'd say you're talking to
someone who was like suicidal for
several years struggling with addiction
waking up every day getting high 247
first thing in the morning as soon as I
get out of bed taking opioids because I
couldn't get I couldn't take a shower
until I was like got some relief from
the pain and like the physical
withdrawals and when you are in that
level of Despair and keep my I was able
to function and continue to like live a
productive on the surface life but I was
like destroying myself like emotionally
and to come out of that thing like I was
thinking about this on the flight out
here I was like man I'm so grateful that
I don't have to depend on drugs that I'm
sober it's just like it's a dream come
true and I think that that level of
gratitude has served me but the other
thing I'd say is when I so I was working
in finance just getting by I mean we
were like I married my wife best
decision I ever made we had beautiful
children that part is all like within
everyone's grasp finding the right
partner is like so critical I can't
stress it enough if
I there are things that my wife and I
disagree about but the one thing that I
knew for sure was that this is the
person I want to be the mother of my
children and maybe subconsciously in a
Freudian way I wanted her to be my own
mother but we don't have that kind of
relationship but iates problems I often
think of that where she is like the like
she the mom of our house like she cares
for all of us but we have very distinct
roles like I deal with all the finances
and all the like TP we have the most
traditional like old school relationship
like Dad does the dad's stuff mom does
the mom's stuff um and it works for us
it doesn't necessarily mean it has to
work for everyone but I would say that
when so when I when I got sober we have
four kids I'm living in New York I'm
commuting from Westchester and I was
like this is a losing proposition man I
I can't keep living like this I'm I'm
driving an hour in the morning two hours
sometimes at night to get home I'm
making just enough money to be
comfortable but I'm not rich I don't I
don't have anything extravagant we had a
nice house but not like a not a frakin
house that you'd pull up and be like
holy [__] what's this guy do it was like
a house and um I was just like I don't
want to do this anymore and and but now
I have huge responsibilities we sold our
house moved to the Palisades most
expensive place on Earth probably I mean
it was so crazy expensive we rented a
house and I I don't want to make it
about money but just to give context for
people like I was far from Rich and we
rented the only house we could find that
could accommodate us $2,000 a month I
was like dude this I'm on a I have a
Runway now and that that Runway is short
and I got to figure this out and I'm
working at a tech startup that I didn't
think would succeed but I had blind
faith that I would figure this [__] out
and I don't know what when I say I
didn't sleep for 6 months like dude I
didn't sleep I was like constantly
panicking like having panic attacks of
like but I'm I'm going to figure it out
I don't know how and long story short I
convinced my friend Jack McDow who ran
the Palisades group and asset management
firm in
La they didn't really have marketing he
wasn't really growing the business and I
convinced him to hire me to run Business
Development he had like two billion in
assets under management but it was all
like separately managed accounts so it
wasn't like a$2 billion hedge fund with
two in 20 fees and uh he was like you
don't really have experience and I BAS
basically said I'll do it for free I'll
work for free now no health insurance no
nothing like you talk about putting your
freaking balls on the line and he let me
do it and in a few weeks it was obvious
it worked two years later he had five
billion in in assets and we had three
different discretionary funds like real
headed like hedge fund style funds that
paid real fees and it was like like the
goldby race I was like I did this holy
[__] I can't believe I did this but it
was literally like I'm just going to
figure it out and for whatever reason
like the the Stars just aligned and the
universe just was like this guy believes
in himself we're going to reward him
like I I I always have a hard time
accepting accepting the fact that I did
something I always think like oh I got
so lucky there it lined up perfectly and
I was in the right place at the right
time versus I made that happen but I
also think that that humility and that
not getting overconfident prevents you
from getting out over your skis and
doing something stupid which you could
argue that that might have been a stupid
decision had I gone bankrupt and like
embarrassed my whole family but instead
we I rided the ship we started to like
have you know create a little bit of
comfort for ourselves at least that I
wasn't like I could sleep and um you
know when coid kicked in the kids got
sent home from school and it was just
too much four little kids on iPads and
um my wife went to Vanderbilt and she's
like let's move to Nashville now that
you're working from home because my boss
at the time my partner Jack was like you
can do this for yourself and work for
yourself and I'll keep you on as a
consultant and give you a year of Runway
and I was like dude I don't think I can
do this who's going to hire me to raise
money for them and he was like dude this
guy was like this guy Jack McDow was
like my [__] Guardian Angel he
believed in me more than I ever believed
in myself he's one of my best friends I
love this guy he was like you can do
this and I was like dude I can't he's
like I'm G to pay you x a month for the
next year and I was like that's more
than enough and he's but I had raised
like a discretionary fund so he's like
instead of me paying you a bonus and a
salary I'm gonna give you this monthly
retainer go do your thing and when we
raised the next fund you come and raise
it for us as a consultant and I did and
the first mandate I raised money for was
David Sinclair's uh life bioscience in
Boston and uh I'm working from home coid
started I've always said to my wife
imagine if we could make like New York
La Finance money but live in like Austin
or Nashville and she was like let's do
it so I couldn't bring I love living
here I was driving here thinking I
[__] love Malibu running biking but
no one else had that connection in my
family they they were like they liked it
here but they weren't like I'm in heaven
so she was like let's go to Nashville I
said I can't bring myself to do it you
go find a house that you like if you
find it buy it and I'll move there so I
saw the house the first time when we
pulled up and moved in yeah you I think
he told me that last time that's un
that's an unbelievable story um but the
point I wanted to make is when you all
and it sounds cliche again I know but if
you're waiting for everything to line up
like as soon as everything's lined up
I'm going to start my business or I'm
going to move to um Puerto Rico and take
advantage of the tax shelter and bl if
you're waiting for the time to be right
[__] stop wasting your time it's
never I'll have kids when everything is
sort of set right like soon as I have 5
million doing this and that do it now
that that day never comes never and you
know to the people who would look and
say like I want that
I wish that there was a formula or an
easy answer I could say do this this
this because people ask me all the time
I'm like brother I don't have the answer
for you but all I can tell you is you
have to believe in yourself to the point
where you're like willing to die to win
I will win this race or I will die
trying it's funny after the second stage
of that Gooby race I haven't shared this
with anyone the video but I sat down and
made a video of myself where I'm like my
elbows bleeding and I like just cuz I
wanted to remember how I felt and I'm
basically talking to the camera and I'm
like I'm [__] destroyed and I like
literally St getting emotional I'm like
I don't know how the [__] I'm going to
keep doing this I I can't bear the
thought of running 24 miles I have I am
destroyed I'm I'm a mess I'm bleeding
I'm like I don't know what I'm doing
here I I don't know what I'm going to do
and like I start get choked up and I'm
like I just wanted to make it like I
said for my wife and for for myself and
to show my wife like what I was
experiencing in the moment without being
dramatic and it was like I think it's
pretty moving yeah that's wild I you
know I think
belief in yourself yes but also this
reflex to action right this idea of
execution not waiting until everything's
lined up before you take that action or
not sitting on your ass until you have
the whole road map of how you're going
to get from point A to point Z like
anybody who's successful has to begin
and you start to just move forward and
it's like stuff shows up right in your
like immediate you know view only at the
last minute when you need it to show up
in order for you to take one more step
and that's how everything gets done and
gets made and you got to develop a
capacity or or a comfort level with that
level of
uncertainty the
biggest thing of all that is like aside
from believing in yourself and all that
stuff is like you can't be afraid to
fail like fear is the worst and I say it
all the time and like Teddy Alice talks
about this and he learned this from
custado and it's like you know it's a
well-known expression but the coward and
the hero feel the same exact emotion
when confronted with a situation it's
just how do you act in response to the
fear the hero is like okay I see you I
know you're there here's how I'm going
to handle this the coward is like ah
[__] this run or or or ignore so you can
be afraid to fail it's just what are the
actions that you're taking in the face
of that Fe you can be fearful you can't
be afraid cuz you will fail like if you
try to do epic [__] you're going to fail
it's it's I mean the the the the fraking
road to success is littered with
failures like anyone who's who's who's
been super successful has had failures
along the way it's impossible to like do
epic [__] and not have failures I mean
the best athletes in the world uh what
this kogi went to win the Boston
Marathon he got beat it was the last one
he had if you told me Kip chogi was
going to get beat at something I'd be
like I got 10,000 that K chogi wins even
money and he lost but that's it's like
the expression what would you do if you
knew you couldn't
fail that's the motivation to try these
things like these other endurance races
where I'm like oh my God I'm so scared
I'm afraid to even mention that I might
do it which is part of the reason why I
mentioned them because now I'm like I
know people are going to be like when
are you doing that when are you that's
the obvious question you know is it is a
pilot light lit now and you're going to
go off and do all these Ultras and I
think that there's something really cool
and amazing and interesting for you to
explore in that world and I think it's
such a beautiful Community it's very
different from the marathoning community
um and I think you'll really enjoy uh
you know everything that that has to
offer at the same time it's like are you
running towards something or are you
running away from something yeah I think
I I could probably make an argument for
both although I would say knowing what I
know now I'd say I'm running I'm I'm
running away from things less than I've
ever been I'm like aware of the
challenges that I'm facing emotionally
and spiritually and um and just to put a
name on it like what are those
challenges I think a lot of it is
insecurity and like just being aware of
like how much of this is performative
what am I doing for like the accolades
and affection and attention of others
versus like a sincere desire to like
explore what I can and can't do and and
I do think that
again not to sound cliche I do think
that there's a huge element of that that
I do just that's kind of my personality
it's like what else can I do like I've I
like doing this I like saying like I
don't know uh free diving I I don't have
any interest in free diving but how far
could I free dive oh that seems real
scary what if you can't get a deep
breath and you get stuck down there can
you die H man that might be interesting
to try scares the [__] out of me but
like those are the kind of things where
I'm like hm what else can I dry that
would be scary and not because I don't
want to fail but I do want to like kind
of explore those things in a healthy way
but I also want to be sure that it's
like I want to be very conscious of what
is the motivation there yeah it's tough
too because it's not one or the other
you can have that but also like I'm
Restless at home I'm I I don't know
something doesn't feel right like oh
I'll sign up for a race I'll sign up for
an adventure and it's like that's when
you're running away you're like you're
you're just like putting the blinders up
because you don't want to deal with
whatever is making you uncomfortable
about sitting still in your own home
yeah that could be it there was um I
will say I got a lot out of the element
with the goby race of like the planning
and like the
Strategic thought about food and
supplements and like which supplements
do I bring I take a lot of supplements
primarily from momentus but I was like
which of these supplements are so necess
necessary that I'm willing to carry them
for 6 days what made the what made the
cut yeah good question I um I took a
daily multivitamin and two fish oils
daily from momentus and I took um
athletic greens I took momentus recovery
powder which I was like man I don't know
if I should carry this recovery pot or I
should just abandon this and eat the
food and go straight food the
freeze-dried stuff but in the end I was
so glad I had the recovery stuff because
I don't know about you but after a huge
race like a marathon or an epic like a
long hard effort I don't have an
appetite for like 5 hours sometimes so
to force the recovery powder down every
day was like thank God I brought this
cuz it got calories in right away and
then I just forced myself to eat the
calories throughout the day that was the
only part I was that that was tolerable
I was hungry a lot but I was also like
so deep in the pain cave that I was like
I can only tolerate so much food so it
made that calorie deficit like a little
bit more palatable you know the the rest
day sucked cuz I was just like I could
have eaten like you know freaking half a
cow I was just like so hungry for and
and so hungry for like fruits and
vegetables because I was like dude all
I've been eating is this freeze dried
crap like I just went want something
like with like substance or like some
real vitamins and minerals and nutrients
not all the sodium and like processed
[__] yeah did they do it differently at
at like marathon toab where they have
these big camps set up at the end of the
stage and I think do they feed you
dinner there or do you have to bring
your own food is that the difference in
Marathon theab is they just provide a
roof like a shelter you're sleeping on
the sand from what I understand but
there isn't some kind of big barbecue
when you waiting for you when you not
only that they don't boil the water for
you like and I'll I'll give you guys
some pictures and videos that shows like
what the camp setup looked like there
was like just some big like almost like
barbecue grills with kettles on them
where they would boil the water and then
there was like just a pile of bottled
water sitting in the desert so I was
like my wife was like well at least they
gave you cold water I'm like cold water
the water was like an inferno I mean
like one was boiling and one was hot but
they would boil the water and You' pour
it into the freeze-dried food in
Marathon theab I think you have to
actually carry the little like um little
stove thing that you could boil your own
water but a lot of those meals you can
pour the water doesn't have to be
boiling and dude you're so hungry and
like on queer street that you're like
[__] cold water warm water it it
didn't matter um and I think that and I
also think marathon theab is like
majority is like over sand like really
loose sand just seems so much harder
people like oh you're going to do
marathon the sub I'm like you couldn't
pay me 100 Grand to do that race I've
like I've been there done that I don't
want to sleep in the
sand the next one will have no sand
involved the funny thing is the guy who
planned out the course um Spanish guy
he's like listen I got a great race in
Namibia it's the same exact thing as
this but we sleep in hotels and great
meals every day I'm like oo now you got
my
attention um what is the supplement
routine when you're at home um in the
morning I'll take like most mornings
I'll take tyrosine and most of this is
like part of the hubman protocol I'll
take tyrosine uh like an alpha GPC for
Focus if it's a work day I don't take it
on the weekends and I'll take
NN um after workout I take the momentous
um recovery Shake scoop of athletic
greens creatine uh um a
multivitamin uh two fish oils zinc and
vitamin D and some cartil and then at
night I'll take the Sleep pack from
momentus that has like theanine
magnesium yep yeah and appenine yeah
exactly the other one I get crazy dreams
when I take that dude I'm a junkie when
I go to sleep and I have crazy dreams
I'm like this is like a dream this is
like a dream come true even a nightmare
I'm like I'm sober uh when you're in
that kind of dependence every time you
wake up you're reminded of like you
ain't going anywhere without those drugs
did you you're going on vacation for a
week do you have 55 perco sets ready to
go to get through the week now I've only
got 40 okay so the last two days you're
going to be in withdrawals and make it
miserable for
everyone that puts it into perspective
yeah so when you have like think about
those things like I'm overwhelmed with
gratitude and just full of Positive
Vibes you're 52 yeah 52 May yeah so how
are you thinking about about the next
couple years where do you see yourself
in 3 years 5
years how are you staying on top of your
Fitness and and all of that I I don't
feel old like I don't treat myself like
an old man sometimes I see like gray
hair in my on my head especially on my
beard and I'm like [__] I'm old yeah and
it's it panics me I don't like it and uh
I know dude it's I don't I don't part of
me doesn't like having the beer cuz it's
super white I feel like I'm a hundred
years old but my wife likes it all right
I I'll do it fine but like you know I
just can't do it I'm way too insecure in
vain I feel like oh my God I look so old
but do you do you feel like this
sometimes you look in the mirror and
you're like wow I look old I don't feel
any different than I ever have in my
whole life like I don't feel different
than when I I mean I feel emotionally a
lot more mature but from a physical
standpoint I think it's maybe the
soreness becomes so gradual that it just
like the only thing that's massively
noticeable is the eyesight like I can't
see my phone without read glasses at 45
and it just got a little bit worse every
year which is depressing but I don't
feel like I don't feel like I'm
deteriorating at all and I don't know if
it's because I've just stayed active and
stayed busy and just refused to give
into that or if I maybe I'm lucky like
from a genetic standpoint that I've been
able to adjust but I was talking to to
the other day cuz I had my LP little a
and APO B levels tested and they were
super high like Panic level high and I
like dude this is causing me massive
anxiety cuz I'm like oh my God I don't
even think there's a way to lower these
because it's all genetic I I don't eat
an unhealthy diet I very rarely have
ever eat meat you know primarily fish
and uh so to think that I have this it
was like man the day I got that
diagnosis my wife's like what's up I was
like I was like in a bad place and I was
like I'm going out to run it's scary
that's really scary I literally was like
you know in how long ago was that two
months uh-huh said to my wife like I'm
going to have a heart attack I'm I think
I'm going to die now like this is crazy
how is this happening I went out that
day and ran like the hardest interval
run ever and she's like what are you
doing I'm like I refuse to give into
this like if if if I'm going to if this
is going to happen let's do it now I was
just so depressed so now I've been like
trying to cope with it and figure out
like what am I going to do and so I'm
starting to like formulate a plan and
figure out do I take a stat and what do
I do it's I got a couple people uh for
you to talk to definitely including Rob
Moore yeah yeah Rob and Rob and Andrew
have been massively helpful yeah you
don't want to [__] around with that and
it's that thing where doesn't matter how
fast you run sometimes like in to's case
like who would have thought right um I
think there are certain lifestyle things
that you could tweak that could help
that and you know whether or not you
need a Statin you need to explore that
and figure that out quickly but it's
yeah that's when you're really kind of
confronted with your own mortality and
it goes back to control is this
something you can control or not which
is a scary thing yeah and it's not
something that's easily controllable and
that's what's been hard to deal with
it's like man what am I going to do but
I'm going to formulate a plan and I'm
definitely going to take you up on
talking to anyone who's willing to talk
to me so yeah the cardiologist when he
was talking to me he's like yeah I'll
get you on a stat and I was like n I'm
not taking a stat and he's like why I'm
like I just haven't heard good things
about him I don't know why I was just
emotional and I was like I'm take my
chances so when he sent me the report
he's like uh I told patient of risks
Patient responded I'll take my
chances oh that went in his notes yeah
yeah well he's covering his ass oh of
course of course yeah that's all right
you might want to rethink that yeah no I
definitely do it was just when I when I
heard it I was like I'm not that that
level like I'm not on statting what are
you crazy but I think you're you're a
you're a good case study for use it or
lose it like you feel the way that you
feel because you continually apply
pressure right so you feel like you're
30 because you've been training in a
certain way for a very long period of
time and you've been able to kind of
maintain uh whereas most people drop off
and they're rebuilding and they rubber
banding and I'm in the middle of that
type of experience because of this lower
back problem that I've had like when I
was you know when I did how was I 51
when I did otel yeah I felt [__]
great and now I've had this back issue
which has forced me to be more sedentary
and to not express myself physically in
the way that I choose and like in order
to just feel like who I am and now I'm
finally on this path of healing and I'm
seeing results and now I can move not
like I'm not out killing it or anything
like that but I can kind of get out
there and you know ride my bike and go
to the pool for the first time in a long
time man and I'm like oh my God this is
what it feels like to be me like I'm so
grateful like you take this for granted
and it gets taken away for from you for
a little bit and they're just simple
things they're not like material things
they're just like I need to do these
things for my mental health for my
physical health and just to like feel
like I'm myself and to be able to
reconnect with that now and see a path
forward it's like I feel so [__] good
and I feel I had forgotten what it feels
like to what a lot of people don't
realize and they should is that a rich
man has a million problems and a sick
man has one I after I came back from
Chicago on Sunday morning came home hung
out with the kids had dinner Sunday
night didn't eat anything offensive I
don't even like something vegetable
salad same thing my kids ate Sunday
night dude I woke up I had like a
stomach bug or food poison and I threw
up for like 24 straight hours it like it
was so bad I was like almost like
begging to like just God please put me
out of my misery take me out I can't do
this my head was in a vice grip I
couldn't stop throwing up and all I
could think was like I'd give up
everything in my life to be healthy I
just it was I I literally was like am I
going to die like this is UN unable I
can't move I'm frozen on the bathroom
floor I can't stop throwing up and that
was like such a reminder of like dude
slow down I think my body was just like
yeah enough cut the [__] go be
desert then go to Chicago run a Beer
Mile flying around almost like just
ignoring Common Sense tactics of like
dude you need to give your body a rest
so I took like three days off from
running first time in like a long time
that I've had multiple days in a roll
off wow when you think back on the
habits and the routines that have
contributed to your success Beyond we
talked about the supplements we talked
about the 10 miles a day what are some
other things that you build into your
daily regimen that you think have been
important in moving the needle
definitely number one uh performance
enhancer sleep I I go out of my way to
get proper sleep that doesn't always
happen but like I don't really drink I
mean I've never been a drinker like my
recovery never involved like oh my God I
can't have a drink so like if I might
have a drink every couple of weeks but
that's not my thing um so but I also
think alcohol like reeks havoc on your
sleep and and just your whole recovery
so I don't really do any of I don't
partake in things that I used to partake
in so I really emphasize sleeping and I
also emphasize consistency like I keep
it moving and and people it's funny I
always get so many like um internet
coaches that like hey let me tell you
how you should be doing this I'm like
what the [__] about me tells you I need
help like this works for me I maybe I
could be better if I had recovery built
in but it isn't all about performance
some of it is just about mental health
like i h i I feel like I emotionally I
need to just move my body in the morning
it gets endorphins fire it is what it is
it's like my blessing and my curse but
um so when people offer that advice I'm
always like a little taken a back like I
don't want to be rude to them but I'm
like dude [__] worry about yourself
um are you still working with Mario oh
yeah yeah Mario's like he knows he knows
the drill but you know if we're not in
if we're not getting ready for a
marathon he doesn't send me daily
training every day he's just 10 12 weeks
out he puts together very specific and I
follow it blindly but um I think that
the consistency of training the point I
was going to make is so so if I'm
feeling destroyed and run down so I'll
just run really easy and that works for
me I like come back feel refreshed the
next day I might feel stronger if I
don't I continue to run easy I never
unless we're in that 12we session and
then I just follow the plan and on the
easy days you have to run easy you
physically can't do track workouts
followed by hard long runs and not feel
run down so my easy days are just 10 m
super easy and I know that that for a
lot of people they be like that's crazy
you shouldn't do that and maybe not but
that's the system that I use and what
about the gym routine yeah so three or
four nights a week I lift weights I try
to mix it up all the time like a
shitload of pull-ups push-ups and
sit-ups out the Staples and uh I'll do
some bench press and kettle bells I just
try to keep it interesting all the time
and do some squats leg work
um hamstring stuff because the
hamstrings always get overused in
running it seems like that's a big piece
in your resilience as you continue to
age up and your ability to kind of
recover and maybe even you know in the
GOI desert your ability to kind of get
on all fours and do some of the you know
real technical like slogging through the
mud and climbing over rocks kind of [__]
that play to your advantage just the
Pure Runner yeah I definitely think my
experience as like kind of like a hybrid
athlete a hybrid training helped me a
lot just with everything like resilience
in general like the ability to go every
day like I know what it's like to train
every single day so to do that and just
dig deep for five or six days Six Days
Seven Days six stages was okay it was
longer but if it's long for me it's long
for them and that's what I kept telling
myself is like I'm suffering but guess
what so are they yeah um the last thing
I wanted to ask you I put it out on the
internet like hey Ken's coming in what
should we ask him and got a bunch of
questions uh but there was one that I
wanted to kind of end the conversation
with which is uh somebody said what
would Ken say to to you know someone
like like myself who's just lazy I can't
I just can't I can't get I can't get off
the couch I can't I can't get myself
into that gear I would say exercise like
your life depends on it because it does
and if you're lazy like hey do your
thing right that's I I you can't it's
like what would you tell someone who's
addicted to drugs and deep in the throws
of addiction I'd say when he's ready to
get healthy he'll get healthy but you
can't tell someone to get healthy you
can't tell someone to get get sober you
know this mhm I mean that's why they
have interventions and then they usually
don't work they don't work yeah yeah
because you can't you can't will
somebody into willingness right if
honestly if this person was talking said
dude I just don't feel it I'd be like
brother then don't do it for yourself do
it for your wife do it for your children
have some pride in yourself like dig
deep man doesn't you don't have to run
marathons but like you can't [__]
walk for 30 minutes a day you can't do
push-ups those little things become
contagious they become it becomes like a
snowball rolling down a mountain it will
gain momentum but it's just like
straight physics a body in motion will
tend to stay in motion and a body at
rest will tend to stay at rest unless
acted upon by an outside force you
you're in control of this like you only
have one life why would you this is the
only thing you're in control of is your
body why would you squander and neglect
the [__] greatest gift you could ever
receive like look at what I look at what
people have been able to do with their
bodies even myself like to go to the
desert and put myself through this like
I can't believe my body did this and uh
what else can it do and it's awesome and
I would say like
don't cut that's that's get over that
that's a [__] poisonous mindset yeah
being lazy is like yeah I'm lazy I don't
want to work well you ain't going to
[__] eat CU you ain't going to get
paid like it's also a story yeah that
gets reinforced every time you tell
yourself that you're lazy that's right
right so do you have the capacity the
power to tell a different story and that
Different Story begins with taking one
step and to your point about um an
object in motion stays in motion at
least do enough for as long enough that
you create momentum yep because there is
a physical law with momentum but there's
also like it's like the force there's
like a spiritual power to it why is it
when you're on a roll and you have
momentum that it's just easier to keep
going and when you have that intervening
event that throws you off your game and
you get interrupted it's so [__] hard
to get back so when you have that
momentum you got to protect that like
your life depends on it yeah because if
you can continue that momentum you're on
a roll like you can you can literally
just ride it out into a a completely
changed experience of your life that's
right and but it starts with a first
step so first of all like I said earlier
it's the reality doesn't matter what are
you telling
yourself people might think I'm crazy
I'm telling myself I'm definitely
winning there's another part of me
saying like you're going to get killed
but the voice that do you override that
do you consciously say okay I'm going to
tell myself I'm winning because I'm
trying to mute out that other voice are
those things at War each other I can
literally see them debating each other
like I have the thought of like oh my
God we're going [__] when the guy
passed me for third I was like oh my God
we're gonna think we're GNA be [__]
happy to get in the top five and then I
hear myself talking to myself like dude
cut the [__] [__] this is one day
tomorrow we're gonna bounce back and
we're gonna get these guys next time
we'll sit on them we'll do this a little
different we're going to try this and
it's this that voice only needs to be 1%
louder 51 to 49 the alpha voice wins and
like I said the reality doesn't matter
the only the only the story you're
telling yourself matters and I'm I'm
hyper aware of that when I'm in the
moment and uh but it doesn't make it any
easier I have my normal person I have
all the same concerns and like
insecurities as everyone I'm like please
God don't let me embarrass myself so
many people are watching I'm such a
[__] Big M I told everyone I was
doing this but I think part of it is
like creating this accountability
exercise for myself because I've
mentioned anything on here for instance
I know everyone's going to ask me about
it and now I've backed myself into a
corner and I'm like all right maybe I'll
lose but I can't be afraid to fail
because I'm going to try and just not
trying is not an option right and uh
stay off of LinkedIn please don't send
me L LinkedIn messages LinkedIn
incoming uh it's always a pleasure to
talk to you man I I you're such an
inspiration and uh I I always get so
much out of uh everything that you have
to share and um I think what you're out
doing you know leading the way as an
example of what's possible uh you know
for for people in our age bracket is is
super cool and I think when I I think
about Master's athletes like this is a
new thing like when we were kids there
weren't people in their 50s out you know
it's like exactly so when you're
breaking records you're like yeah that's
great but in you know my estimation in a
100 years from now like whatever records
are standing right now are going to get
eclipsed 100 fold because we are not we
but like I think people are exploring
human capacity at older ages for the
very first time no but I think it is we
I think like a thought leader in this
space like 100% like I'm so incredibly
proud of you I freaking love you I love
the people in this community I love the
people that I'm friends with I'm I'm
like I said before I'm overwhelmed with
gratitude the fact that you want to hear
what I have to say is like doesn't even
seem real to me at times I was such a
fan for so long and I just was just
working tirelessly in the dark in the
cold just doing my thing and eventually
it was like holy [__] this is unique
well everyone's not doing this literally
I like
I'm I'm shocked this is I but I guess
they're not well every year there's
fewer right exactly exactly but this I
would say endurance bullets has given me
the greatest gifts in my life like I
said it's helped me carve out a a world
in which I don't have to answer to
anyone else I'm responsible for myself
anytime I've been in a position to eat
what I kill essentially like live on
your own like you don't make any money
you don't get paid like you don't do
deals you don't get paid cool I like
that I know that
I'm terrible at processes like when I
worked at the Palisades Jack is my
friend Jack it would drive him crazy
because he's a banker he's like an NBA
CFA uh Excel wizard like this is a
fraking intellect math major type I
would take no notes I had no systems I
just had relationships and he would tell
me what needs to get done and I would
get it done and he would literally be
like I [__] hate the fact that you
are able to do things the way you do
them because it doesn't make sense it
shouldn't work there's you have no
accountability you have no records of
anything and I'm like I know I'm
terrible as an employee that's why now
I'm unemployable but if you tell me what
needs to get done at what date I will
live and die with that success if I
don't get done don't pay me but if I do
get done I'll take a zero or if like
you're going to pay me $100 if I do it
pay me zero if it doesn't get done pay
me 200 if I do it most people are like
you know what I'll do that and I'm like
cool I don't know that I'm going to be
able to do it but I'm going to another
pressures on I'm going to do it so that
was part of the struggle of working in
finance and then working at an asset
management like Asset Management hedge
fund private Equity those guys are
[__] intellectual they are dialed if
you go into a proper private Equity or
real Venture fund like an El Catan my
buddy Michael farell shout out those
guys are they are pros and I am not the
best fit in that environment because my
processes suck I know it but if you tell
me you need something done I know and
the people that know me know it's
getting done and I just the way I get it
done sucks you know it's like the goby
desert I don't know how I'm going to do
it but I'm getting over that Finish Line
first right endurance so to wrap up
Endurance Sports as teacher yep as as uh
spiritual guide um
self-reliance Integrity being true to
your word uh developing the capacity for
resilience the
uh the The Reflex towards
action fear of failure versus uh how did
you distinguish it fear uh fear of
failure versus you there was being
afraid being afraid right how do we
distinguish between those two you can be
fearful but you can't be afraid yeah so
much good stuff man well I will just say
that I'm so gravable I'm so happy that
for the opportunity to be here and um
yeah I hope that um people get something
out of this and if I can be of service
to anyone I'm very easy to find and very
easy to reach even for the haters um
especially on
LinkedIn on straa on straa sometimes
someone would be like after the be
milees someone wrote a comment tagged
their friend and said you know Joe Blow
you got to take this guy down that kind
of comment I can't ignore I'm like
[__] you know where to find me
I'm the easiest person in the world to
find me find anyone can get it I'm not
hiding from anyone and my like why would
you even respond I'm like I don't know I
feel like they poked me and now I've got
to respond yeah you might want to work
on that the one bring your APO B down
that might be that might be one of the
ways to do it the one thing I will say
in closing is my friend jelly roll
taught me an awesome lesson and if you
don't know who jelly roll is he's the
[__] nicest guy in the world country
music star former rapper former convict
just incredible inspiration he said to
me one time I was telling him someone
left a shitty comment on my Instagram
and he's like Ken
your Instagram that you're referring to
we're looking at it together he's like
there's like 300 positive comments here
and one [__] said something shitty to
you he's like do you know how
disrespectful and insulting it is to the
people that left you nice comments that
you're going to only respond to the
[__] [__] and I was like it like
hit me like a ton of bricks I'm like
you're right why wouldn't I take time to
be like write a personal thank you to
everyone who took the time to say
something nice to me and it was a
incredibly valuable lesson of just like
I still struggle with but it doesn't but
it helped put things in perspective
because I was like yeah man and I also
would say imagine if I was saying to
Rich you got to see what I did on I went
on slow twish or let's run and I trolled
the [__] out of some pro athlete I I
talked so much [__] about him I accused
him of horrible things unfounded and I
said all nasty [__] about him you'd be
like why H just because I think that
he's an [__] why is that I don't know
I don't even know the guy you'd be like
are you a [__] loser what productive
person has time to to be disrespectful
and negative towards another man who's
out there doing [__] in the man in the
arena like worry about yourself so I've
tried to do a better job of tuning out
the like negativity although there's not
a lot of it but there is some and I'm
always like taking back because I'm like
why would someone dislike me I've never
done anything bad to anyone anyway
that's great advice it is amazing when
you think of it in that context because
these people who took time out to say
something nice you're ignoring them Y
and you're giving all your attention
to some somebody who just said something
nasty and they're getting that person is
getting exactly what they want which is
your attention which is crazy can you
imagine being the person that's my point
is imagine being the person who's like
yeah I talked [__] about someone and
they responded to me like what a loser
like I can't imagine nobody who's out
pushing themselves and doing hard things
and you know trying to better themselves
is wasting their time talking [__] about
people
in% or at least if you're going to say
it's come and see me on a race and be
like you suck and I'd be like oh really
why is
that all right man we got to disabuse
you of that Obsession so next time we'll
do a whole therapy session on comment
sections we talked about that last time
I think too so this is still hanging you
on some level and uh we got to get your
blood markers down but I love you buddy
than you you're the best um I really
appreciate you coming here today and uh
let's go grab something to eat hell yeah
thank you for having me and thanks to
everyone for tuning in appreciate this
community guys are the best yeah peace
[Music]
out that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voice in change in
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. roll.com if
you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcasts on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review and or comment supporting
the sponsors who support the show is
also important and appreciated and
sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason Cameo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davy Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel CIS thank you
Georgia Wy for copywriting and website
management and of course our theme music
was created by Tyler Patt Trapper Patt
and Harry matthys appreciate the love
love the support see you back here soon
peace plants
[Music]
namaste